tellement
bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
au parlement européen à bruxelles pour
une nouvelle émission d'europe hebdo et
dans cette émission un reportage le
drame de lampedusa et ses centaines de
cadavres retrouvés en mer ya six mois
sont encore dans les mémoires
mais les européens sont divisés et
préfère encore attendre pour mettre fin
aux naufragés l'épineuse question du
droit d'asile renvoyés à juin 2014 dans
trois mois après des élections
européennes l'europe face à
l'immigration clandestine c'est notre
débat du jour nous irons à mellila
l'enclavé espagnole au maghreb à la
rencontre de ces jeunes qui risquent
leur vie pour atteindre l'eldorado
européen mais avant l'actualité c'est ce
référendum en crimée face aux forfaits
russe l'europe sans force
vladimir poutine a tout lieu d'être
d'être satisfait les européens ont réagi
à un minima moscou à découper une partie
d'ukraine et les européens font profil
bas
c'est l'une des crises les plus sérieuse
depuis la fin de la guerre froide
les européens ont pris des sanctions
contre 21 une personne très oligarques
russes mais aussi huit responsables
ukrainiens de crime et dont le premier
ministre côté russe parmi les personnes
sanctionnées
on trouve des parlementaires de la douma
des membres du ministère de la défense
c'est vingt-et-une personnes verront
leurs avoirs gelés et ne pourront plus
voyager en europe
côté sanctions elles les européens
frappe moins fort que les américains les
etats unis ont également édicté une
liste noire mais elle cible des
responsables plus proche de vladimir
poutine
on pourrait tout à fait imaginer des
représailles russe mais pour l'instant
la priorité de poutine c'est de
poursuivre à marche forcée l'annexion de
la crimée la leçon elle se résume en une
phrase
hormis par une intervention militaire on
ne peut pas changer le statut actuel de
la crimée et personne en europe ne veut
se battre pour sébastopol si les
européens condamnent les procédés
inacceptable de moscou le référendum
illégal et illégitime pour le reste ils
ont constaté tous ensemble que leur
marge de manoeuvre est très réduite et
qu'il ne pourrait tabler que sur un
espoir que les dirigeants russes
confronté à une baisse des
investissements étrangers chute du
rouble ou une menace de véritables
sanctions économiques accepte enfin le
principe d'un dialogue sur l'avenir de
l'ukraine
autant dire qu'ici à bruxelles personne
n'y croit
voilà alors nous a rejoints sur ce
plateau pervenche berès bonjour vous
êtes eurodéputés socialistes première
question toute simple j'ai envie de vous
poser
qu'est-ce que vous inspire le résultat
de ce référendum 96 6% résultat à la
soviétique
vous le dites c'est un résultat
soviétique mais c'est un résultat qui
n'a pas de sens juridique pour nous les
européens nous l'avions dit et le fait
qu'il se soit déroulé avec ce résultat
mam ne donne plus tôt nous conforte
plutôt dans l'idée que ce référendum n'a
pas de valeur pas de sens juridique
parce que quoi c'est contraire au droit
international ses traits au droit
international et qu'on droit contraire
au droit qui prévalait avant que ce
référendum soit organisé en ukraine elle
même est ce que nous on a pas quelque
part une vision un peu european au
centre et après tout les ukrainiens
russophone aurait le droit de vouloir se
rattacher à la russie pourquoi pas non
mais la question de la crimée est une
question complexe et on sait qu'au cours
de l'histoire
y compris en remontant à catherine inde
russie l'a écrit mais a pu changer de
statut donc on le voit bien que c'est
tamayo extrêmement sensible dans l'
équilibre stratégique de cette région
c'est bien pour ça d'ailleurs que
vladimir poutine a lancé cette offensive
sur la crimée mais ça n'est pas parce
que c'est une question stratégique pour
la russie que les européens doivent
accepter ou peuvent accepter que le
droit soit bafouée et que l'intelligente
hérité de l'ukraine soit ainsi
totalement ignorée et violet on a
l'impression que vladimir poutine
quelque part des filles l'europe et que
face à cela la réponse des européens
c'est un peu de l'eau tiède quand on est
descendus sans ces sanctions là c'est
une étape chacun a dit
elle était prévisible on avait dit qu'il
y aurait une graduation des sanctions
c'est le niveau 1
première étape le conseil européen
devrait appelé les européens à
diversifier leur approvisionnement en
énergie a confirmé l'accord
d'association avec l'ukraine pour venir
en aide à l'ukraine
bien sûr c'est un point sur lequel les
européens auraient dû aurait pu se
mobiliser en un mot la crise fait le
résultat et je crois qu'ils sont
aujourd'hui très déterminés à agir
ensemble car ils savent que face à la
détermination de vladimir poutine
ça n'est qu'ensemble qui peuvent
exprimer une réponse adaptée matin il
est une personne visée par part par les
européens
les membres du ministère de la défense
des pontes de de crimée est-ce que c'est
assez les américains frappent plus fort
une frappe directement des personnalités
proches de vladimir poutine
ce que c'était a cessé ses sanctions
écoutez si le point d'équilibré sur
lequel nous étions d'accord et je crois
que les manifestations de soutien à
l'ukraine sont aussi quelque chose où
les européens sont très engagés vous
l'avez vu il ya l'aide financière qui a
été proposé à hauteur de 11 milliards
qui pourraient être augmentés ce sont
aussi des signes concrets de la volonté
des européens de venir soutenir
l'ukraine
pardon cette ligne rouge
au delà de laquelle les occidentaux
bougeront que se passera-t-il demain si
vladimir poutine annexe de ma l'est de
l'ukraine à kiev
la région de donetsk la région de
kharkov qui est aussi une région
russophone
qu'est ce qui l'empêcherait vladimir
poutine de faire cela il y avait les
bruits de botte dans les frontières oui
bien sûr et on voit bien joué a coulé
voit bien que la stratégie de bagnères
poutine
c'est une stratégie vieux comme la
diplomatie c'est à dire que face à une
difficulté intérieure face à une
déstabilisation à l'intérieur face à une
crise économique intérieure grave qu'il
n'arrive pas à surmonter
il cherche une projection extérieure qui
lui permet de refaire consensus autour
de sa personne dans des conditions
absolument anti démocratiques en russie
face à ça les européens ne peuvent pas
faire le jeu de l'escaladé et nous
devons rapidement pas les moyens on peut
pas se battre pour sébastopol bat pour
sébastopol en anglais on ne va pas
engager un conflit armé aujourd'hui avec
la russie personne n'ya intérêt mais
tout le monde a intérêt à ce que la
situation se détende et chacun mesure
combien la russie est aussi dépendante
de des économies européennes que ce soit
dans la distribution dans l'achat de gaz
soviétique pardon dans l'achat de gaz
russe lapsus sans doute révélateur d'une
stratégie nostalgie de putschistes
justement pervenche berès vous parler
d'économie européenne il ya des
problèmes concrets deux bateaux de
guerre sont vendus aux russes en ce
moment à saint nazaire des mistral 200
mètres de long des hélicoptères que nous
allons leur vendre un milliard deux
cents millions
eh bien écoutez ce qu'en dit laurent
fabius le ministre des affaires
étrangères vous nous écoutez on réagit
juste après
si poutine continue comme ce qu'il fait
à ce moment là nous pouvons envisager
d'annuler ses ventes mais pas simplement
parce que ces dégâts tiff aussi pour les
français il faut bien comprendre mais
nous demanderons alors à ce moment là
d'autres je pense notamment aux
britanniques de faire l'équivalent avec
les avoirs russes des oligarques à
londres les sanctions doivent toucher
tout le monde
voilà laurent fabius qui est prêt à
annuler ses ventes des cd emplois
français et européens qui pourraient en
pâtir
c'est la solution vous voyez bien que
ces affaires ne sont pas neutres y
compris pour les français même une
sanction ça n'est jamais simplement une
ligne sur une feuille de papier c'est ça
un impact réel pour tout le monde
d'où l'importance de ce que laurent
fabius a indiqué dans cette interview la
nécessité que tout le monde soit
solidaire et que l'europe parle d'une
voix ça concerne à la fois les
britanniques sur les avoirs des
oligarques russes qui sont installés à
londres
ça concerne aussi certains liens
industriels que l'allemagne peut avoir
avec la russie de vladimir poutine
mais si les européens parlent d'une bois
alors ils ont une capacité de sanctions
qui dans une gradation est au delà de ce
qui a été aujourd'hui fait avec la liste
des vingt-et-une personnes une étape
très importante
vendredi première pas un pro signature
de l'accord d'association avec l'ukraine
la première partie c'est quoi le soutien
un pays dont l'intégrité territoriale
elle est bafouée c'est quoi de toute
façon vous savez bien que l'union
européenne a vocation à avoir ces
accords d'association avec les pays de
son voisinage
donc c'est une étape très importante
dans le contexte historique où nous
sommes
ça doit s'accompagner d'une aide
financière puisque l'ukraine doit faire
face à une dette à hauteur de 35
milliards dans les années qui viennent
et que l'europe s'est engagée à hauteur
de concrètement cet accord d'association
ces coiffes pour l'ukraine
c'est un européenne c'est moi comme
avantage c'est un outil pour relancer
son économie pour offrir à son économie
des débouchés dont elle a tant besoin
je crois que c'est mardi prochain
vladimir poutine annoncera
officiellement l'annexion de la crimée
est-ce que c'est pas un peu provocateur
et humiliant pour les européennes
la montée en grade de ces sanctions ce
serait quoi
les proches de vladimir poutine visez
vous avez vu que pour l'instant les
européens vont soit organisée avec les
américains notamment dans le cadre d'un
g7 où le président obama va participer
donc il ya une vraie volonté des
européens avec les américains de prendre
la mesure de ce qui est en train de se
passer en russie et la tenue de ce g8 à
sotchi semble plus que menacée on ne
peut pas dire que les européens restent
les bras ballants simplement il ya dans
la gradation de la réponse
une mesure à prendre des risques et des
conséquences de l'engrenage qui pourrait
être qui pressent pour s engager les
affaires étrangères pervenche berès
n'était pas votre domaine de
prédilection mais pourtant on a presque
ça vous touche est cette affaire
ukrainienne non vous savez j'étais
suffisamment longtemps parlementaire
européenne pour avoir au début ma
carrière officielle commission des
affaires étrangères de ce parlement
européen et lorsque j'étais
administrateur à la journée nationale
j'étais à la commission affaires
étrangères donc j'ai bien sûr ce sont
des affaires majeures pour l'union
européenne
merci je verrai ce d'avoir accepté notre
invitation maintenant place aux
reportages direction mille hilal enclave
espagnole située au maghreb où ces
jeunes veulent rejoindre l'eldorado
européen l'europe face à l'immigration
clandestine en france les policiers
chargés de démanteler les filières
d'immigration clandestine interpelle
quasiment toutes les semaines des
trafiquants de faux papiers des passeurs
reportage avec les membres de lochrist
l'office central pour la répression de
l'immigration irrégulière et de l'emploi
d'étrangers sans titre c'est un
reportage de florence gaillard et de
diane cambon
6 heures du matin en banlieue parisienne
ces policiers s'apprêtaient à
interpeller un homme chez lui après
plusieurs mois d'enquêté et d'écoutés
téléphoniques
ils vont arrêter pour trafic de papiers
d'identité priot réveil
l'homme ne se rebelle pas reste aux
enquêteurs à perquisitionner son
domicile
il y avait chez qui la sono lent mais
vers les toilettes vous savez pas vous
savez pas de à qui ça appartient on a
découvert sur la sueur
petite centaine de dossiers en fermant
préparés et prêts à être déposés en
préfecture qualité à l'aide de ballons
seulement de faux documents mais
également de documents authentiques
l'homme interpellé surnommé junior se
serait fait passer pour un employeur en
phase de recrutement
il aurait réclamé aux candidats leurs
actes de naissance ainsi que d'autres
documents administratifs
les candidats n'ont jamais revu le
prétendu patrons mais ils ont été
victimes d'usurpation d'identité junior
aurait revendu 6000 euros les dossiers à
des émigrés clandestins qui se
procuraient ainsi des papiers sous une
identité usurpée
la garde à vue pourra être prolongée
jusqu'à quatre jours puisqu'il s'agit de
criminalité organisée
junior est auditionné et les documents
mis sous scellés sont examinés hiver
mais riche avec à l'appui donc une
fausse facture internet
l'extrait d'acte de naissance la copie
de sa cni il se fait délivrer une
nouvelle ceni c'est un office qui est
constitué d'environ 110 personnes qui
travaillent au démantèlement judiciaire
de filières d'immigration clandestine
ce soit des filières de passage donc de
traverser la frontière ou des filières
de maintien sur le territoire qu'ils
peuvent utiliser notamment la fraude
documentaire comme support pour se
maintenir sur le territoire l'office
procède à une interpellation comme celle
ci par semaine en moyenne
juniors risquent jusqu'à dix ans
d'emprisonnement pour l'aide au séjour
irrégulier d'étrangers en france une
lutte contre les séjour irrégulier
d'étrangers en europe qui n'empêche pas
des milliers de jeunes de tenter leur
chance
chaque jour ces jeunes migrants
maghrébins sont arrivés en espagne mais
ils sont coincés dans le port 2000 il a
une enclave située en afrique du nord
sur la côte marocaine des autorités ne
peuvent pas les renvoyer au maroc car
ils sont mineurs livrés à eux mêmes ils
vivent des aides des bénévoles
en attendant une occasion de gagner
l'autre rive de la méditerranée
je crois ce qui arrive à mellila l'une
des portes d'accès à l'europe ont déjà
franchi les frontières très fermé le
maroc et l'enclavé espagnole sont
séparés par ce triple grillage et
pourtant des centaines de clandestins
parviennent à y entrer chaque année
certains se cachent dans des véhicules à
double fond en déboursant jusqu'à 4000
euros dans l'hacienda et ben on a crevé
sous ce siège était dissimulée une jeune
de 16 ans une femme d'origine
subsaharienne plus fréquents
le passage avec de faux papiers
marocains pour 400 euros une option
privilégiée par les migrants algériens
l'algérie est à moins de 100 kilomètres
d'ici donc pour eux l'accès est très
facile par la frontière car il passe
avec des faux papiers comme s'ils
étaient marocains et entre
tranquillement en marchant et se dirige
ensuite vers le centre
ils disent qu'ils sont algériens pour y
être accueilli la dernière méthode n'est
pas la moins dangereuse
la voie maritime chaque année des
migrants illégaux se noie en essayant de
rejoindre l'enclavé à la maj depuis la
côte marocaine
ceux qui réussissent se retrouve comme
tant d'autres à mellila loin encore très
loin de leur but
voilà nous envoie sur ce plateau sylvie
guillaume bonjour vous êtes eurodéputés
socialistes vous avez beaucoup travaillé
sur ce dossier d'immigration à vos côtés
mario borghezio bonjour vous êtes
eurodéputé italien membre de la ligue du
nord la droite populiste
alors on l'a bien vu dans dans ce
reportage l'europe elle est confrontée à
une migration économique une question
toute simple qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire
tous fermés c'est inhumain d'ouvrir ce
serait l'anarchie qu'est ce qu'il faut
faire
sylvie guillaume vous avez raison fermé
c'est difficile d'autant qu'il y a
beaucoup de route qui font arriver
jusqu'en europe et lycées
ouvert est effectivement impossible dans
une situation de crise économique dans
laquelle nous nous trouvons
internationalement et en europe donc ça
veut dire qu'il faut qu'on sache réguler
les choses mieux que nous faisons
maintenant avec un principe de
responsabilité devant des personnes qui
vous l'avez vu dans le reportage sont
obligés de payer on profite de leur
vulnérabilité de leur pauvreté pour
essayer de faire en fait du trafic
d'êtres humains pour rentrer en europe
avec solidarité parce que c'est vrai que
les pays qui sont aux portes de l'europe
sont plus exposés aux migrations que
ceux qui ne le sont pas et puis je pense
aussi donc cette régulation au plan
européen doit permettre que les voies
légales soient plus développées de
manière à lutter contre les voies
illégales et dernier élément qui sait
très bien montré dans notre reportage
il faut une action beaucoup plus
importante contre les passeurs qui
profitent de la vulnérabilité des nîmois
mario borghezio ces jeunes qui veulent
accéder à l'eldorado européen ça vous
inspire quoi
oui je pense que il y a un devoir de la
part de l'europe d'être avec les pays de
la méditerranée qui sont riches de main
d'oeuvre et qui n'ont pas de travail
donc il faut créer le travail dans ce
pays fort et aider les pays de la
méditerranée de pays de l'afrique ça
c'est une mission humanitaire vrai de
l'europe
tout au contraire l'invasion de
l'immigré clandestin qui deviennent
inévitablement le le gain qui réalise le
gain des organisations criminelles en
france à l'italie par les organisations
criminelles et surtout par les mafias
c'est un péril pour la sécurité de nos
populations et sont aussi très dangereux
envers l'opinion publique qui commencent
à se demander si tous les immigrés ne
sont pas criminelles donc essai et ça
c'est pas vrai parce que nous savons
très bien qu'il y ait un qui vient
migration régulière qui est utile à nos
pays
donc c'est un but qui devrait avoir à
chaque pays de l'union européenne de
lutter sérieusement et pas seulement
avec des démonstrations de deux suivants
rochelle comme celle ci il faut être
vraiment effective sur la lutte contre
l'émigration des clandestins mais je
pense que la france aujourd'hui n'est
pas là la france n'est pas n'est pas là
mais il y a seulement des opérations de
façade mais en réalité en france vous en
italie il arrive beaucoup beaucoup vous
êtes vous vous êtes italien on a donné
ces naufragés de lampedusa qu'est ce
qu'on fait on leur laisse est une c'est
un défaut de l'état italien qui ne
réussit pas défendre la frontière on les
laisse pas se noyer quand même nom mais
il faut combattre efficacement contre le
trafic de immigrés clandestins et qui
réalise là l'activité la plus criminelle
c'est celle du trafic d'êtres humains
sylvie guillaume sur ces naufragés sur
ces naufragés de lampedusa la question
était le droit d'asile la question était
reportée à juillet à juin prochain si je
ne m'abuse
après les élections après les élections
européennes
qu'est ce qu'il faut faire quand on est
face à l'urgence face à l'afflux massif
de d'immigrés clandestins comme comme ça
a été le cas l'an pedrosa il faut faire
quoi une opération militaire comme l'a
proposé emma bonino ministre
italienne des affaires étrangères à
l'opération militaire de l'est de
l'europe pour pour réagir à l'urgence
qu'est ce qu'on peut faire pour éviter
ces drames
le débarquement d'un très grand nombre
de personnes à lampedusa a été
consécutif notamment au printemps arabe
et au fait qu'un certain nombre de
jeunes gens sont martin massivement de
tunisie à un moment très précis de
l'histoire mais c'est vrai qu'il y a
continuellement des passages quand la
mère n'est pas trop mauvaise
et même quand elle est très mauvaise
malheureusement avec des naufrages et
ses traversées
quand elles sont en dehors des
phénomènes d'urgence comme je le
signalais tout à l'heure et sims
phénomène massif comme après le
printemps arabe
il faut effectivement qu'on puisse
laborde et les abords des halles manière
de sauvegarder les personnes qui sont en
grave difficulté qui risquent de se
noyer
donc en évitant le refoulement des
personnes qui est contraire qui
contrevient aux règles internationales
est arrivé sur place il faut que les
états membres qui je le redis sont les
plus exposées à ce flux de migration
soit aidée par l'europe
ce quelqu'un l'italie a été au moment de
l'afflux massif comme vous l'indiquez de
personnes qui venaient de tunisie a
beaucoup été aidée alors est ce qu'elle
a fait correctement son travail à ce
moment là manifestement je crois qu'il
ya eu un certain nombre de défaillances
qui fait que les personnes ne voulait
pas s'arrêter en italie et je voulais
continuer pour aller notamment en france
mais il faut distinguer je crois les
phénomènes d'urgence dans lequel il faut
que chacun se sente concerné et que
c'est la solidarité européenne
s'expriment et le flux continu du
personne qui doit être effectivement
contrôler et réguler comme je
l'indiquais au début de
mon propos des salaires dans cette
immigration il faut distinguer les
demandeurs d'asile à ceux qui sont
persécutés dans leur pays d'origine et
les migrants économiques comment on fait
pour distinguer la di stasio marion
mourgue azur oui mais c'est une question
totalement différente
il y à une question des demandeurs
d'asile qui ont le droit d'obtenir
l'asile est en principe humanitaire que
nous reconnaissons mais il ya une grande
affluence de immigrés clandestins qu'ils
ont un père il est alors il faut que
l'europe renforce les les agents se
confrontent ex qui n'ont pas les moyens
pour organiser vraiment le contrôle de
la méditerranée crise économique oblige
le budget de frontex à celle agence qui
est chargée de surveiller les frontières
a été réduit nos sièges à lampedusa
l'europe parle parle de contrastes et
les négations produits mais fabien elle
fait bien en effet les réactions à ce
que vient faire son député riad
laissaoui solidarité c'est lutter contre
le trafic d'êtres humaines ça c'est la
vraie solidarité humaine je reviens à
l'instant sur la distinction parce
qu'effectivement désormais les flux de
migration sont souvent mixtes c'est à
dire que il y à une partie des gens qui
viennent pour des motifs économiques et
d'autres parce qu'il ya réellement une
persécutions dans leur pays
je crois que le vrai problème c'est que
l'asile est utilisée aussi un peu de
façon la demande d'asile est quelquefois
utilisé de façon indistincte parce que
le gagne fut important de demandeurs
d'asile que les procédures d'asile sont
très longues
en europe dans mon pays l ont été
jusqu'à deux ans donc c'est
effectivement très très long et pendant
ce moment là
les gens ont l'impression qu'ils vont
pouvoir bénéficier d'un statut
intermédiaire avant non seulement de
repartir puisque 25% seulement les
demandes d'asile au plan de l'union sont
rétablis donc je crois qu'il faut
effectivement pas distinguent
il faut effectivement pardon distinguer
ce qui relève de la procédure d'asile
qui rentre dans des procédures très
concrète et très précise de
détermination qui ne souffre pas en
reste quand même de l'immigration
clandestine c'est souvent aussi un
problème de politique intérieure en
italie comme en france
je vous pose d'écouté marine le pen la
présidente votre collègue
la présidente du front national elle
utilise cet argument de l'immigration
clandestine pour les élections
municipales on l'écouté vous réagissez
juste après c'était dans un meeting à
perpignan
l'émigration en particulier dans les
chics pour les municipalités pas
seulement pour l'état mais bien aussi
pour les collectifs à la pratique la
transparence les coûts liés à cette
animation qu'en dessinant la forme les
concitoyens moi je pense que nos mais
pourrait effectivement exercer une
pression en demandant des compensations
financières à l'immigration clandestine
a un coût pour les municipalités pour
les villes
sylvie guillaume on a trak cet extrait
n'est pas pris complètement au hasard
madame le pen c'est une campagne dans
tout comme députée européenne dans une
ville au moment d'une campagne
municipale en france dans une ville par
ailleurs où son compagnon est candidat
lui même à l'élection municipale
donc on voit bien qu'il n'ya pas de
hasard et je crois que ça témoigne aussi
bien de la manière dont et
instrumentaliser la question de
l'immigration par ces forces politiques
tels qu'exprimés qu'elle est exprimée
par madame le pen ou finalement sur
fonds de vulnérabilité de crise
économique il faut trouver des coupables
il faut balancer des chiffres comme ça
qui ne veulent rien dire on a entendu
tout et n'importe quoi sur la question
de la demande un chiffrage on a attendu
70 milliards de coûts on a entendu 3,6
milliards on ne sait pas ce qu'on compte
on ne sait pas ce qu'on met dedans est
tout sans doute au niveau des yeux c'est
qu'ils disent sur les partis qui choque
au contraire aux partis comme le front
national aux ligues
il disait que nous nous faisons une
revitalisation
mais s'ils ne veulent pas ça ils ont
seulement à résoudre le problème le
problème s'est péjoré dès que vous
parlez contre nos le problème c'est
devenu et les horribles les
augmenter les périls pour la sécurité
publique
c'est augmenter soit à un niveau
national soit au niveau territorial et
donc et c'est nous qui avons les gens
j'aime pas franchement compris la
démonstration mais je suis je saisis
l'idée générale qui est de considérer
qu'il y a besoin effectivement de bouc
émissaire et que cela serve
politiquement à faire des démonstrations
de l'est malheureusement ça ne s'arrête
pas bon c'est que ça ne s'arrête pas
malheureusement ça va être aussi extrême
est le vrai prix tant question centrale
pour les élections européennes
on nous parle de 25 % des sièges pour
l'heure nationale la question centrale
c'est charles type de l'europe et de
l'euro
la keynote comme combattre pour la
sécurité et l'immigration
j'ai une autre question centrale ça
n'est pas la question de la migration
même si je le redis qu'il faut réguler
les choses et avoir des chiffres précis
et des idées claires sur ce sujet le
vrai problème c'est qu'on peut résoudre
cette crise économique
faire en sorte que les gens retrouvent
du travail que la croissance revienne et
je crois que de ce fait là on aura et un
regard totalement différent sur ceux qui
viennent d'ailleurs tout cas merci à
vous d'avoir accepté notre invitation
c'est la fin d'europe hebdo la semaine
prochaine vous retrouvez nos ramadier
cette même place d'ici là bonne suite
des programmes sur les chaînes
parlementaires